so you currently have or want to have
raspberries that is a really really good
idea they are by far my favorite fruit
the Tangy sweetness and the popping
sensation of all the individual little
little loes inside the berry just just
does it for me they they seriously are
my favorite fruit
but they can be quite tricky to grow
especially if you do the right thing at
the wrong time so what does that mean
for growing your own raspberries at home
well it means there are a few things
that you have to know about this plant
once you know these things it'll forever
set you up for big harvests moving
forward and to make sure that you always
do the right thing at the right time of
the year so without wasting any more
time let's take a look at how
raspberries grow what you need to know
about them so that you can make
decisions to maximize your harvests and
the ultimate growth of this tree moving
forward before we get into some of the
content I just want to thank all of my
loyal subscribers that have been with me
for many many years and for those of you
that are seeing this video for the first
time and coming across my content for
the first time welcome thank you for
watching this video please do subscribe
so that you can continue to take in
content and knowledge that I am busy
sharing with you if you find this video
to be useful please click in the link
below to buy me a coffee you can join up
as a member on YouTube as well there are
many different ways that you can support
my work and this channel moving forward
but let's move into raspberries
raspberries and more
raspberries so to not make this video
too long what I'm going to do is I'm
going to very briefly touch on the most
important thing that you know about
raspberries and then I'm going to send
you off to my Blackberry video why
because in my Blackberry video I talk in
detail about this specific topic which
is primocanes and
floricanes raspberries are very similar
to blackberries in that they grow on
primocanes and floricanes and you need
to know the difference between them
because ultimately how you treat and
handle each one determines what's going
to happen with your your Harvest and
your crops so there's a detailed
explanation on the Blackberry video I've
put the link in the description below
I've tagged it somewhere up here that
you can watch as well but as a very
quick summary Primo canes are the green
new canes that come out of the ground in
early spring I'm not going to touch on
fruit bearing quite yet cuz I just want
to stick to Canes your flurry canes are
last year's canes that have overwintered
and are now putting on side shoots
primocanes are the first ones to come up
and will continue to grow vertically
they will not grow horizontally
floricanes stop growing horiz
horizontally and they start growing
vertically that is a very important
differentiator between the two you will
also see in the stems the key Telltale
sign between primocanes and floricanes
are the color of the stems floricanes
second year old growth is gray and brown
and brittle it's also got flakiness on
the back your primocanes this year's
growth that has come out in Spring will
be green and nice and thick and tender
and towards the end of the season we go
a a light brown color your floricanes
over time will start silvering so that
is ultimately how you tell the
difference between them now why is this
so
important because
depending on the variety you have and
now we moving into the next chapter
which is you need to know the variety of
raspberry or Blackberry that you have
because that is going to determine how
you treat your
plant what you get is three types of
raspberries you get Summer bearing
Autumn bearing and
everbearing now in blackberries you
mostly get everbearing which I'll
explain to to in a bit but in essence
summer bearing raspberries are the ones
that bear the fruit on the Floric canes
of the previous year and they can come
in as early as late spring into early
summer but then what happens is the new
growth comes up and it's sets those
canes for the following year then you
have Autumn bearing raspberries Autumn
bearing ones are the ones that you can
mow down cut down weed eat down as much
as you want you can cut the whole plant
to the ground and in Spring the all the
shoots are going to come up all the
canes and at the end of summer towards
Autumn they're going to give you one
huge flush of raspberries but you're not
going to get them in early spring or
early sorry late spring or early summer
then what you get is this one in front
of me which is the Heritage variety
which is by far around the world the
most common raspberry variety and this
is an everbearing variety everbearing
meaning you keep both canes you keep
your Primo canes from this year and you
keep your Flor canes from last year on
everbearing raspberries like this one
you'll see on the picture over here this
is a florane the plant looks worse for
where because we are in Autumn and we
are now getting below zero nighttime
temperatures so it's starting to lose
its leaves but what this is showing you
is there's a strong cane That's growing
and on the tip of the cane even over
here there are flowers growing up here
all over the place on everbearing
raspberries the plant will grow and you
will find that you get a harvest of
raspberries on the growing tips of the
primocanes that is very important to
know then what happens is the following
year what you will get is on that
primocane that produced on the tip the
one year is now going to produce lateral
shoots the next year and on the lateral
shoots on the ends of those you are
going to get plasters of raspberries so
you can start to understand now that if
you P the wrong cane at the wrong time
you eliminating a harvest all together
so your your Floric canes which is your
seconde growth which is going to give
you the lateral shoots they're going to
give you fruit late spring early summer
because they are already established so
that's how you get that nice
early succulent fruit early on in the
season which you don't get a lot of your
other berries then what happens is the
your floranes will start to go a little
bit dormant you can see these are all
pretty much dead and your floranes are
going to take over and they towards the
end of the growing season which is now
for us which is autumnn are going to
just explode with berries on the growing
tips of the canes that is what gives you
your Autumn late summer autumn berry
harvest so you can see how having both
canes present gives you berries
throughout the season now it's important
to note that the Heritage variety which
is the everbearing variety will give you
smaller yields more often throughout the
year whereas if you look at a summer
bearing or an Autumn bearing they're
going to give you a lot of berries in
one go so it's all up to you as to the
preferences you want you might want to
get a summer bearing an Autumn bearing
and an everbearing variety so that you
have a huge amount of berries throughout
the year that is completely up to you
that brings me into the next chapter
which is what do we do with pruning to
make sure we don't end up messing around
with the wrong canes at the wrong
time well first of all go back to
chapter one which is what are primocanes
and floricanes how do you tell the
difference between the silvering and the
brown the first year and second year and
once you can identify the differences
between the bark when the tree is
dormant so not tree sorry the bush is
dormant it's lost all of its leaves
you're just going to have a whole bunch
of canes and what will happen is your
Floric canes second year growth would
already be oh Thorns very brittle and
this is just snapping off and it's dead
wood so your floricanes are going to be
quite brittle already so those you are
going to remove completely all of your
seconde growth which is silver silver
growth should have died off but if you
have a whole bunch of growth on it it's
okay it would not be doing much in the
third year in any case so all your
silver branches with flaking bark
they come out during winter all of your
primocanes which is this year's growth
which are going to be next year's flurry
canes those you want to select now you
need to decide where you are growing
these if you have them in a pot like I
do then you want to have no more than
five strong
primocanes because if you have more than
that the plant is going to become too
weak and you only want the thick strong
ones and I'll show you the difference
between thick ones and weak ones down at
the bottom here we want your strong ones
because they're going to continue to
grow and they're going to support a lot
of lateral growth and berries you don't
want these spindly little sticks to to
be your foundation for next year's
growth you don't want to reduce them to
less if you absolutely have to you can
probably go three so between three and
five but I would try and stick to five
so that you get a good har Harvest then
what you do is put your steaks in like
this and here are 1 2 3 4 and here's the
fifth one five so these are the staks
that I use and you just simply take this
Branch over here which is a
primocane and just fix it to it so that
you got a nice open V shape you stake
them up in in the winter so that next
year's spring when your Floric hands are
going to put on lateral growth and start
putting berries on and get heavier
they're not going to fall over the
branches or the canes won't snap they
they're quite elastic so if they do fall
over it's okay you're just going to find
that the the fruit spoils pretty quickly
so now that we know primocanes Flur
canes we know varieties to look out for
and now we know pruning what else do we
need to know well it all comes down to
feeding and fertilizing and watering now
what I have found
with raspberries is that they generally
don't require a lot of care and
attention the only thing they do need a
really close eye on is watering these
beautiful big raspberry leaves take in a
lot of moisture so you need to make sure
that your moisture level in the soil is
always at optimal the tree will talk to
you so the leaves will droop you might
even get some burn on the outside where
they get really crispy but your tree or
your bush will talk to you so listen to
it also to be able to put on a lot of
berries that are very moisture dense
berries it needs a lot of moisture so
with raspberries you don't want them to
be water logged cuz they don't like
water logged but you also need to make
sure they have enough water so soil is
very important with raspberries you want
a relatively free draining but not very
free draining that the water just soaks
through so you have to have a lot of
organic matter that can hold on to
moisture but you don't want a lot of
clay or things that are going to hold on
to moisture for a long time so that you
end up getting things like root rot
fertilizing I've done a a video that I
can show you which is based on Folia
feeding I only Folia Feed The
Raspberries I don't give them anything
in the pot because of the the surface
area of the leaves Folia feeding Works
incredibly well for them so that's
that's all that I do and besides that
make sure that they're in a Sunny Spot
this has Sun all day whole day and it's
a very happy plant besides all the dying
off leaves because it's going into
dorcy and that is in essence in a very
quick summary everything you briefly
need to know about raspberries I am
going to do a dedicated pruning video in
a couple of months time when the bush is
completely dead so that we can go into
detail and I'm going to talk you through
every single cut why I've done what so
you can better understand how to prune
your raspberries but for now the
foundation is there please do go and
watch the Blackberry video as well and
thanks again for watching this video if
you do like this content and like what I
do please support me by buying me a
coffee subscribe to the channel and if
you have any questions or comments
please drop them below because as always
I will get back to you
until next time happy GR
[Music]